The joe rogan experience and I realized why I'm so fucked up.
It's wrestling.
That's what fucked up your head.
Oh,
it just made me crazy.
Sitting some hot ass room,
fucking getting tortured and getting beat up.
My,
my coach is a world champion at 17 from Iran and then he left.
He left the country and then couldn't wrestle in the Olympics,
which she probably would have won because he didn't have his green card,
so he would bring in all these super bad asses to just kick the shit out of me.
My whole high school career,
they have a deep,
deep background in wrestling.
Man,
they fucking tortured me,
Ron.
It's just,
I remember the iron sheik.
Yes,
she legit wrestling.
She was the legit wrestling.
I had them in a car.
I'm not kidding you man.
He was a world class
for like an hour.
He's a good dude,
man.
Is.
He came on stage with me in Toronto.
I did this.
We'd store this.
We'd show in Toronto.
They do the show.
It's like the underground comedy show.
They do it in a weed store and the weed store is up like a bong shop in the
front and a comedy club in the bag.
And you go into the back and you can't see 10 feet in front of you.
You are in the clouds.
Man.
I'm not joking.
It's ridiculous.
It's the worst hotbox ever.
No ventilation whatsoever.
Every now and then again,
they opened up the back door so nobody dies.
That's it.
There's no air Arab shoes.
All you're breathing,
you're breathing in,
breathing out weed.
It's,
the whole room was filled with wheat and the iron sheik was in there getting
high as fuck.
And he came on stage while I was up there.
He came in and fucking this,
this is all your video of it online.
It's hilarious.
Uh,
me and him just talking to them
stage.
But yeah,
Iranians.
So imagine me at 15,
16 cut weight.
You're fucking Sana.
And I have some 40 year old Iranian dude massaging me,
read my backend and credit card down all my sweat.
And people look at us like,
what the fuck?
Why is that man?
Hey Sir,
you can't buy him that way.
He'd be muttering to meet the Farsi.
You can't just scan him,
sir.
Do you want to fuck him?
You're going to have to hold him down.
Oh boy.
I realized the same 24 hour fitness we always went to in Aliso Viejo was a gay
hangout hollow.
This is getting married.
Betty and I worked out at 24 hour fitness and there was this dude who was the
manager there.
It was a cool guy.
We just talked to him and uh,
they had sent him over from the Santa Monica Place.
He was like a real personable,
real friendly guy.
Like he,
you know,
real easy to like.
And so,
uh,
the Santa Monica police brought him in because they needed to get that place
cleaned out because it had basically become just a fuck house.
Close the shower,
hose them down everywhere.
It'd be common condoms.
But my buddy ended up working.
That's how I find I,
but it ended up working at the same place and they used to have to trap dudes,
gay dudes that were fucking in the sauna and stuff
and raped [inaudible] the cops came because it was relatively stations.
How people die,
Bro.
Don't trap me in the [inaudible] out of here,
man.
You know what's incredible?
I'm looking at,
and he starts about three rows up.
Check out the people three rows and beyond looking at fat.
Do
you guys have no fucking idea what Atlantic city is?
I've never been hell first time ever been white trash in from all fucking ports.
It's 15 to get on the bus and to go to Atlantic city.
Here's the clinker,
they give you $10 in quarters when you get to Atlantic city.
So they basically give you $10 back.
Then they give you a book of coupons for another 50 to eat to try to keep you
there all day.
So if you go,
let's say at the eight o'clock in the morning bus,
you can't leave till five whether you're broke,
whether you wait all your coupons,
you cannot go back on the [inaudible] the rules,
they have a scam every fucking hour on the hour from all points in New Jersey
and New York buses go down to Atlantic city right now.
Half those people sitting there,
I've already lost that money and they're just killing time to the midnight bus
and somebody from the UFC just happened to give him a nice tickets.
They're sitting there,
they don't even know what the fuck
bookmaker,
who's going to win the fucking the Yankee game because that's how they're going
to bounce back on Sunday and they could go down the shore and they look at them.
They're mummified.
It looks like a fucking old and this is silver right there.
That's Atlantic City for you.
Where's fucking Dana and this room where they bought a gun?
It's good body shot.
Where's Dana White?
He ain't,
nobody reads fine yet.
They haven't showed him the FERTITTA brothers fuck off.
They were in that room to hide
that hide in the main,
like like Fox sports fights.
It comes out for that.
Like towards the end,
like when we have that thing where we sit down,
we start breaking down the fights in the main card.
That's when he comes back.
Oh Linacre.
Oh that you can take it though,
man.
He seemed to some hard shots standing his ground,
These guys are sweating hombre.
Brennan fucking Dana White comes in like deliver on Goodfellows shaking hands
towards the end.
Shaking hands,
boy that people pointing at people.
How about that?
He never hit him.
He had him,
he had him flattened down.
He had his back and he's not crashing him.
He's not blasting with punches.
He's got him flattened down and he's not hitting him.
That doesn't make any sense.
He's also,
he also had a full,
he had a full head joke.
They know,
but he's also 51 that's true.
And a fighter 51 that's true.
You'd,
you'd a hundred percent correct.
And I was like,
I watched everyone.
Right.
I'll watch all the Bella tour.
I'll let y'all UFC.
I'll watch everything,
so the bell tour when,
when the entrance is,
I was like,
this is so dope.
The,
it was kind of like the pride and all that.
Then I was on board.
You have,
I was on,
you had,
he had big brown on board,
but then when Ken shamrock walked out I was like,
what the fuck?
The girl who was singing,
what was that about?
I don't know.
See,
I'm down with that though.
I'm down.
I love for Brian this thing for me when I,
he is a man.
He's really tall and brow,
no matter singer,
not like that.
Tall and Brown.
He's got great hair and a part inspired by the Great Gatsby
I'm working with big brown,
his big brown,
big brown.
You could totally get an opponent's head.
By the way,
when he's laughing at year end trance,
he's going to punch this guy in his big fan of fans and take him down.
Be careful of his game.
I don't want a west side story.
Brian,
how big can surveys to tissue is second to none.
He's really handsome,
doesn't he can turn on a nun.
Don't ever play with me.
Even try,
it's those numbers that you get in.
It's just those numbers in the idea of what you're trying to do and then there's
all the physical shit cause some people are just born with different bones.
They just built,
some people are born like Haji Gracie,
these long ass fucking arms.
They can just cinch Darcy's in from anywhere long triangles.
They can get both your fucking arms trapped in like in a dead orchard.
He can do things with your body if you have these long bodies that you can't do,
but then there's these Paul Harris bodies plus you've got this goddamn gorilla.
I'm lucky.
Strike that guy.
I feel like I'm you.
That's what it's like.
I stand next to him like that was a dark time.
A beautiful bond.
Yeah.
I have a beautiful expressive boys.
Feel like a clod.
Always feel like an extra.
Why Ass Law?
I see a big ass fucking arm over.
You're looking at that arm?
No,
seriously.
On Brian,
you should lift,
right?
Yeah.
Lyft.
Here's the body is a frog.
Hey Bro.
Hey Bro,
what are you talking about?
Show them the guys.
I'm relaxing my head right now.
I'm relaxed to shit.
See Kermit the frog.
My legs are way bigger than that.
So funny
the frog.
What size?
They're Kermit the frog here
currently.
Frog.
That's not bad.
A bad shot too.
That was actually
chairman's arms.
Just like types to stream pipe cleaners.
So silly and he's funny.
He's like the perfect reference that is like,
seriously are you going to make fun of a dude's arm curry?
Kermit the
frog shit of all time.
Currently
take offense.
I'm pass now.
Yes.
Thank you brother.
Thank you.
Jesus Christ.
Said it was in Costa Rica.
I oh,
I used to work in a clinic down there.
He probably has something from there by just a self limiting virus.
Oh by the way,
gone the next day.
I think it was food on my tonsil on my thing.
It's embarrassing man.
He was probably ate a chocolate donut with like powdered sugar on or some shit.
A hypochondriac.
How did sugar gotten?
A little thing that I pokes.
I fucking hate them.
Jesus Christ.
While your sister has spots all over fucking tongue and doesn't do shit.
A bitch doesn't give a fuck.
She eats grass at men's.
Who's up some grass clean mouth.
It's got green mouth syndrome,
foamy green bubbles on the corner of her mouth.
I keep seeing you chewing that cut again.
Shut the fuck up.
Plus he
looks at you with your mouth open.
I'll have four stomachs,
a special type of dude to be with a girl like that.
I'm not one of those guys tried it.
I am not that guy.
I've tried it too.
I like women who were women.
Me Too.
Like women who want to argue with you and they get fucking gangster with you.
That's not interesting to me.
That's like when I,
when I tried,
I had a little affair with a girl on the national Canadian water polo team who
was so hot but she was back was thicker than mine and her hands,
her knuckles when we'd hold hands.
I was like,
well your hands are a little just a smidge bigger than mine and I have a big
problem with that.
See.
That's what I love about my girlfriend,
you,
Ana,
is that she doesn't start any drama or talk shit,
but she,
she knows her the whole,
she'll finish it,
uses it all up given chicks concussions.
She's exhausted by the time she gets to you.
She's very,
she's very and pitches.
I want to see you guys today.
If you guys fucked,
you wouldn't have much say in it.
Don't you lick pussy now?
Boosie no,
come on.
Fucking tire.
Come on down.
She wouldn't be able to handle any time she want to go to sleep.
I know why they call him the Golden Pony.
It's,
he's,
he's surprising.
He has a surprising dick.
That's cool.
It is Dickie.
So Bryce skinny,
skinny but like me,
but he's surprising.
It's more of the ivory pony.
I give it to her.
Good guys.
Serious.
She not to put
her,
put her hair up in cornrows.
I'd give it to her.
Good guys.
I was setting up for my
fucking give it to her man.
That's how you know a guy's mouth.
He's not laying the proper,
I was setting up for my cornrows like you know I do it guys like looking for
everybody to confirm.
Come on guys.
You know
I would,
I would fuck her good fellas.
By the time I was 10 with her,
she needed,
we haven't talked about this fight.
Who the fuck would sign up for that flight fighting Jon Jones at a PR out of
jail or prison.
Enjoy that.
It's going to be on motherfucker will also the amount of people that were paying
attention to that because they felt like Mike Tyson got railroaded.
Like that was a,
that was a questionable decision.
Like what had happened to him,
the lawyers sort of strategy for dealing with the case was that the girl should
have known,
she should've known creation is going tell room that she should have known.
But also she should have known because of the guy that Mike is like the strategy
was to like make it look like he was just a bad guy.
Look,
you should know.
He's like,
he's out there Merkin dudes,
you know,
we'll go watch the Marvis Fraser fight and expect to,
what do you think's going to happen to get alone with that?
No,
he gets that big old day coming up and that was essential
lead their strategy,
the lawyers strategy and that shit does.
Sitting
judge,
I was like,
man,
fuck this.
But the girl
I had a,
apparently allegedly she had a false rape accusation or ready before the
Tyson's.
What's her thing?
So it wasn't,
you know,
it was,
look man,
some of these people
out there in this wild world or crazy as fuck you don't,
you never know if Joey Diaz was Mike Tyson's lawyer will,
what would that sound like?
Listen,
cock sock guy.
Everybody knows you're a fucking creek.
That banging bitches.
You showing you a giant Dick to the fucking general public.
You have to plead the fifth.
I'm going to fucking talk for you,
Mike.
You're the baddest of all time.
We're going to get you out of this.
Oh,
we're going to read books and hold hands.
We're gonna break out the fucking week.
You drop your grandmother
in a fucking hotel.
Rome.
You wait,
lob stuck.
Did you read locked up?
Well you're stuck that
guaranteed like my bike crystal.
Cause you're my friend.
Come on
watching this fight going fucking nuts.
All I was thinking about in the beginning was he's too big.
He's not going to win.
He's just too big.
There's no way he can do this.
He's too big.
Ooh.
Ones about toddler.
That's,
Oh shit.
That was Bob as a child.
Too late though for this round.
But when he got Bob inside controller's working,
trying for a Kimora on a 375 pound man.
That's hilarious dude.
Bob Sat up,
followed him in his guard.
His neck looks fine.
No,
it's not filed.
You shut the fuck up.
380 pound dudes slam your weight and his weight on your neck.
Believe me,
you've got an interview,
said he give the chance.
What's that bait or wouldn't find them.
I worked a little bit,
but he mostly allows you to neck problems come from the lower body,
your hip area.
She out there for
your,
your next hurt because your hips are super tight.
Yeah.
You're one of those guys weird.
Oh Gosh.
I think we have some magical secret.
Kurt's because your ass is a swear to God.
I got a massage and calls me.
The guy wanted to put his fingers up my hands and you let it out.
I swear to God.
He told me that there's a nerve center there.
The releases,
all the muscles.
I wait.
I know.
That's cool bro.
You what me?
I can't hurt anybody's feelings.
I was going,
I know,
but it's cool.
It's cool.
But you know what I think I'm going to,
I'm going to have to take trying to finger your ass
broke cause I'm,
I'm,
I'm good with it.
I just need to this part,
this part.
It's in your hips.
Why don't you talk about that on stage?
It's
a double thing is up my write up my ass.
I was like no,
he gave me a massage.
He was a misuse and then I sat and I was my back really hurt in college so I had
a bad back.
So my lower back and he goes,
he goes,
so he's massaging me and he's touching everywhere but my feet and my is weird.
My feet,
I mean my,
my back,
where's he saw my feet,
my legs.
Then he starts talking about my ass and then he goes,
you hold a lot of tension here.
And I'm like,
okay,
this feels good though.
He's like a massaging my glutes.
And then he goes,
he goes,
I swear to God.
He goes,
so now this is going to be weird.
Maybe in the beginning you have a nerve center,
you have a nerve center right next to your prostate.
And he goes to,
what I do is I'm going to get right up here
and he goes,
how'd to get it right up there with my fingers and I'm in a massage the area.
And what's gonna happen is you're going to let go completely,
but you've got to really let go.
Start letting go now.
And I go,
I was w,
what do you mean?
He goes,
I'm going to put it,
I'm going to have to go in your anus.
And I'm say,
and I go,
no,
no.
I got to know what it's okay.
Because for me,
I'm,
I'm more tight here.
Oh.
So I'm not used to that.
So that's not something I can also,
I'm not used to that.
Yup.
So then I find out they find out that my buddy who is from Jordan and I really
macho dude,
he was Jordan and from Jordan and Germany,
good looking guy,
always combed his hair with a brush and wore tight jeans and pulled his balls
cocked to one side.
And he was very happy with the carrot that I do.
I take this woman to my bed I made that was based on this guy,
and I don't want to say his name,
but he,
he,
um,
I found out that,
uh,
he up fingered,
fingered and then he let the do blow him.
He's like,
oh man.
Well we were all like this.
We were like,
yeah,
but he's from Jordan,
man.
It's probably kind of macho.
We kind of,
Yay.
Wait a minute.
Hold up path.
He's not from America.
Maybe it's like a cultural thing.
Made a minute.
You lift that was talking about it again.
He let a guy finger your ass and then blow you.
That is a gap.
I would imagine.
That's how,
that's what I would say.
No experiment sex.
Not to be,
but I was in college and I saw him have sex with a girl.
I had sex in a room where you know you're younger,
you're like,
oh,
we can't afford a hotel room.
We got to share one.
Right.
I'm having sex.
He's having sex with a girl,
do it.
He bangs girls as well.
He banged girls at guys well,
well and hard and he was working at peace.
I know dudes go both ways,
but he left a guy blowing and I don't give a shit what his fingers.
Right.
This is a guy who hasn't done that other in other places.
Just did it this one time or what's that?
Look guys,
I don't know man.
We didn't really talk about it after that.
We were like,
that's not the first.
That was the one that's like,
you know what man,
we'll give him a pass.
Hold down the control.
Did you find out that he got blown by the,
he the guy who did it,
told my buddy Dan,
very,
very confidentially,
very confidentially because Dan,
my buddy was Dan.
I also got fingered in the bucket.
Dan is a little guy and he goes,
she used to hang out with them straight.
I was fucking tricky university Dan goes,
so dang good.
So,
so check it out.
He goes,
there are a lot of people in here in your midst that have had things with guys.
I was like,
like,
who?
And he goes,
well don't tie it back.
Told you this,
but blah blah blah.
And I was like,
Oh man,
there it is.
But he was so macho,
but you hold on a second,
bag it up.
So,
um,
I remember these stories.
Either you forget the stories and gay guy who tried to finger your ass as soon
as hold this other guy.
This is where the guide or finger his ass and blow them.
But that guy never admitted it to anybody else.
No.
So how do you know if it's even true?
The Guy,
he's a trickster.
You said the guy wasn't even the way she did it because he only told my other
friend who was gay.
It was gay.
Made him say not tell anybody because he's lying.
It could easily be because he's alive and he's got a fantasy of blowing your
heart ass.
Jordanian friend made the story up and then you had bay tells you like it's look
guy blows everybody good.
Let them blow yet.
Yeah,
but it was the next thing you know the guy who was a new assay close.
A big secret.
He didn't want the Gig.
I didn't want anybody to know.
He told,
cause you probably thought your friend would kill him.
The Jordanian friend.
I mean he's a Middle Eastern guy.
It's very likely Zeus or not.
Yeah,
no he was soft,
weak bro.
Crew was pretty a bit about bisexuals that I don't think they really exist.
I think there's gay dudes and then there's really gullible straight dudes who
get talked in to blow and crafty gay dude,
this guy is like making my act real.
That's probably true.
That's what a bisexual is.
There's guys that just crap this fuck my friend Jimmy used to say they're just
greedy.
That's what he used to say.
Well,
like bisexual is their fucking greedy.
Just just one.
Everything.
Eh,
Kimmy,
he's like PME,
Cammie picket team.
He just liked attractive people.
Well,
this guy,
um,
do you still Facebook them every night?
No.
How did you end the sparring session on the massage?
They just gave me,
he finished it up and they said,
well,
he goes,
he goes back.
He goes,
he goes,
I messed it up.
Well,
we dated for a while,
but he charged them what?
He goes,
he goes,
it's something you have to work up to and it's something that I,
I think I can read almost had you for a little bit where you're like,
yeah,
maybe I,
I was like,
that would be weird.
How would I do that?
Yeah.
Wait,
I'm going to tell you something else.
I'm making this up now that I remember it.
I blocked some of it actually
he did massage my tank.
[inaudible].
I swear to God he massage that area because he told me that area is where a lot
of tension and I was like,
this is awful.
I remember my toes kept pointing.
I don't know.
I was like,
Oh,
oh,
oh God.
I didn't want to be
bad with confrontation.
I didn't want to be in Alto,
so I just let it happen.
Yeah.
I was like,
I'm good man.
That's cool.
My lower back,
I get pointed in my lower back muscles that were over here.
Jokes come from probably that's all I do on your tape.
You got a dude besides your team been picked up?
I haven't had a bad back problems since you've been picked up for cross.
He got arrested for prostitution.
When
I don't eat crackers with the crackers down.
This is great.
I just felt the other day,
but everybody thinks that it was fighting,
so I was like,
people like you got arrested?
Yeah,
why?
I was fighting.
I have a whole story about prostitution now.
Well,
no it wasn't,
but that wasn't,
I was not trying to pick up prostitutes.
I see the story that you tell me what he was doing.
I have paid for sex.
Now anyone who knows me knows that and I believe in it.
I just haven't done it.
Believe in it.
I think it's a really,
it does exist.
It's not Santa Claus.
That's true.
And,
and I don't do it.
I don't do it in my adult years because I don't want to,
I don't,
it doesn't turn me on.
And for a lot of reasons I just don't want to be part of it.
But you're married.
Well,
yeah,
but even if I wasn't married,
I wouldn't do it because I have my own responsive.
You want someone to be attracted to you?
Yes,
it is.
I don't want to contribute to someone else's destruction.
There are a lot of reasons.
I have a philosophy behind it.
It doesn't matter.
But,
but,
um,
I come out of,
uh,
Jimmy Burke's apartment.
It's late at night.
I am literally been on a plane and these,
these two blondes were in a car and I look in and I go and they go and I go,
hi,
what are you doing?
I go now months and Emilia,
I'm like,
hmm,
interesting.
And I figured,
man,
I think,
I dunno.
They look kind of hug,
hug her,
and they go,
you want to have a good time now to go?
How much?
And they go,
how much do you have?
And I go,
I dunno,
$5,000 how's that sound like?
That's silly,
right?
So they go,
sounds great.
We'll be right here.
I go,
okay,
I'm going to go right to the bank machine and the other,
of course you can.
So I go to the [inaudible] machine,
by the way,
to get to cash.
I had no cash to get in a cab and go home.
Guess what?
I go to the bank machine guess was waiting for me.
Bunch of cops.
Guess what those calls were?
Cops.
It was a sting operation and they caught me and I looked the cubs and go,
you guys are really going to arrest me.
I said,
$5,000 guy goes,
yeah,
I know that.
Here's the problem.
You got caught up in the suite.
We've got to take in sat next to a guy who was dressed like a woman who was
trying to pick up women and he was peeling his knee.
He was so nervous.
He was peeling his a nail Polish off.
I spent uh,
two days in jail.
It was a lot of fun and I
thank God there were there to protect and serve that do a class for John's for
um,
where I had to go to a class for a,
you know,
whatever.
Like,
you know,
for John John's,
for people that this is also a story you should be telling on stage.
Kind of funny way to,
well just unbelievable pick up prostitutes.
Someone can come up to you and ask you if you want to have a good time and then
when you respond to that,
but it's better to show.
The cops were cool.
They were like,
Bro,
I mean look for me.
By all means.
I get it.
The problem is you got caught up in the sweep in and they were like,
don't worry about it.
They're like,
it'd be knocked down to a misdemeanor just to,
it's a pain in the ass.
I know.
They were all cool.
I mean,
you know,
but,
but you were in jail for two days.
That's not a misdemeanor and I had to make up a story up next to you on a call
and say shit like that.
You gotta know that they'll park.
They were parked.
Yeah.
I think music,
video type shit.
That shit don't exist.
It does exist though.
That's the problem you hear about and fucking penthouse letters and maybe this
is the time when I was getting married the next day or something and I wedding
would be over.
I mean know there's all kinds of shit I just learned when girls go,
Oh,
you want to party.
They're now talking about dancing to some tunes as well.
Do a little drugs.
Hats with rubber bands at the bottom.
Yeah,
they're not
two times in Vegas.
I got,
I got had with a girl,
met her,
she's cute,
we're talking,
hanging out gets get upstairs and we started kissing and she goes and I started
moving.
She goes,
oh wait,
hold on,
hold on.
You have no idea how much fun this could be,
but nothing's free.
I was like,
Oh God.
Then another girl,
we were hanging dancing,
beautiful,
having a great time.
Kissy Kissy,
go to my room and she goes,
oh,
the problem is I have to go to work.
I go,
oh wow.
What do you mean what didn't work where?
Almost like an egg.
She goes,
well,
it cost me $1,000 you know,
I'll lose it.
Thousand dollars tonight if I don't dance.
I was like,
you want $1,000 I've kicked her out of my room.
You 100%
gave her thoughts.
I didn't.
I was like,
no,
I didn't.
I really didn't.
I'd be like,
you know what?
I'm just going to grow.
Well,
you take check.
Of course.
She's like,
no,
actually take credit cards.
She did it.
I just didn't like the way she was trying to pull a fast one on me.
That is hilarious.
Yeah.
Be careful these days,
these hoes ain't loyal.
[inaudible] John,
you know the stories of a John.
My real problem with all of it is when you make something illegal,
it puts all this extra energy in something because you create consequences.
The consequences being you could go to jail,
crime,
you know,
all sorts of issues can happen.
It's a,
is it a,
it's a misdemeanor.
Solicit prostitution,
right?
That's not a Snellen knocked down.
Carry a gun and you could still vote,
but either way,
the idea behind what they're taking,
what your freedom and putting you in the system.
You also probably have to register as some sort of a sex offender
dates you do.
I had a bed in some states in Calabasas for sure.
For sure.
You're [inaudible] man.
I mean it depends on what the fuck you're doing.
You know,
like what are you doing with the prostitute?
When you get this figured out,
you're still making a fire from your job and kind of big consequences.
Here's the point is in countries like Australia where they have legalized
prostitution,
they're divorce rate is way lower.
Sure.
They don't have like all this violent crime,
prostitution need.
First of all,
with violent crime,
they don't need John's.
Okay.
They work in these places where they have security to get people tested.
When people walk through the door,
they know,
you know,
they take their id.
Sounds like the way to go.
We're going to do it regardless.
It should,
I mean legal fuck someone for free,
which it is.
Why isn't it legal to fuck someone from money?
What's the difference?
If it's legal to give someone a massage from money,
why isn't it legal to stick to?
Because that guy's an essential and all free.
Him Free me to consensual adults and all my nerve endings are,
they're two consenting adults and all my nerve endings and I want to relax.
I can't let the guy probably jam his ring finger right in my shit or strong
lower back issue I do.
You can't have him jam his ring finger and his middle finger right up my shit.
Her Louise couple digits.
What's no matter with that opening again,
three knucks deep.